cuando faltan tres días para la primera
vuelta de las elecciones legislativas
francesas una encuesta ipsos sobre este
área para radio francia y france
televisión arroja que la mayoría de las
preferencias un 28 por ciento son para
la nube en la nueva unión popular
ecológica y social de realismo lanzó en
el candidato de la izquierda que
aglutina a todos los partidos de
izquierda y que esperan nombrarlo primer
ministro en segundo lugar con un 27 por
ciento de las preferencias ubica toda la
alianza juntos con sombrero de partidos
oficialistas que apoya a emanuel a macro
ni en tercer lugar el partido agrupación
nacional de la extrema derecha de la
líder más bien lo ven que obtendría un
19,5 por ciento de los votos tomando en
cuenta la primera y segunda vuelta esta
encuesta vaticina que la nube se
obtendría entre
175 y 215 escaños de un total de 577 es
decir no obtendría la mayoría para
nombrar al realizar un primer ministro
en cambio si obtendría mayoría la
alianza oficialista entre 260 y 300
escaños y finalmente el partido de mary
nuevo le pen obtendría entre 20 y 50
escaños que es más de la decena que
tiene actualmente como se explica esto
porque el sistema de elecciones
legislativa francés es de elección
directa con dos vueltas en la primera
vuelta son electos los candidatos con
más del 50% de los votos y más de un 25%
de los inscritos y solo pasan a la
segunda vuelta los dos más votados o
aquellos candidatos que obtengan más de
12,5 por ciento de los votos por eso se
explica que finalmente los votos o las
preferencias no se reflejen exactamente
en el número de escaños lo que sí
reflejan las encuestas es la gran
abstención que parece habrá en estos
comicios ya en el año 2017 fue un récord
de 51 3% para este año se espera una
abstención según esta encuesta de un 54
por ciento